it was the hardest job i've ever done i
spent three weeks living
on the italian coast sailing
eating great food sunbathing because he
wanted me to be very
tan i foolishly thought that every job
was like that you know that um
all jobs in the movies were as hard as
that
[Music]
gattaca i'd only done a couple of
very small british films prior to that
i was just incredibly excited that the
idea of being
invited over to los angeles to make a
film i was
fortunate that it happened to also in my
mind be a really wonderful
script and a great part in that script
jerome morrow was never meant to be one
step down on the podium
with all i had going for me
i was still second best the elements
that i loved about it were this
idea of him being a fallen god in a way
he's told that he's the best of the best
the sort of alpha alpha and uh he fails
and the idea of
what that does to you emotionally and
how he
treats himself physically in response he
sort of drinks and smokes himself to
death really or at least into a stupa
in a way the way we viewed it was that
ethan and i were playing
two halves of a hole that these two
characters
eugene and jerome sort of are one person
played by two people was really
interesting and exciting
playing someone who's paraplegic
to me was a real responsibility of
getting the physicality right
and understanding the emotional
journey uh and uh sense
of of uh being in a wheelchair when i
got to the
to the to the set we had this incredible
staircase
um and i work with uh
someone there who was a paraplegic and
we just went through
step by step literally how he would
ascend this
this this incredible spiral staircase if
he had to
at pace uh without help i worked on that
with him
if i remember rightly for a for a week
or so and what's extraordinary is um
without the use of your legs you know
what other what other parts of the body
you use
and i remember waking up the next day
covered in bruises because
you're using your rib cage much more and
your elbows it was a wonderful um
insight come in
the talented mr ripley i had a whole
pile of literature that i was reading
which were references to
harvard grads and that period and
i was listening to a lot of jazz music
and
uh yeah i took i took saxophone lessons
i've done this a couple of times in my
career where you know you know you only
have a few months i think i had three
and a half
months and of course you dive in
initially thinking i want to be
perfect at this and you realize you're
about 10 years too late you know you
so there's only so much you can do you
have to really screw down on what you
can do
and what is possible so i really works
primarily on the on the
tunes obviously that i was going to have
to perform and then anthony was very
encouraging in getting me into the
location
very quickly very early on so he sent me
down to iskia where we shot most of it
or where we were based when we were
filming it was the hardest job i've ever
done i spent
three weeks living on the italian coast
sailing eating great food sunbathing
because he wanted me to be very
tan i foolishly thought that every job
was like that you know that um
all jobs in the movies were as hard as
that who are you to say anything to me
who are you to tell me anything actually
i really really do not want to be on
this boat both matt
and i came out quite battered and
bruised from that yeah although the
scene the fight
the the struggle was very very well
choreographed because
we were on a tiny boat the camera team
were on a sort of pontoon that was
strapped to the side of the boat but
still the boat had to move and we had to
only be
we could only obviously look in certain
directions because we had to have the
sea behind us
we had a rubber ore uh
which got broken in the first take or
bent
so after that we had to use a real oar
which was slightly troublesome i think
that's where the broken rib came from
you throw yourself into those things and
it was such a brilliant
climax to this relationship and turning
point
for tom ripley when he's frustration and
jealousies and fury bubbles over and
ends up
taking the life of this guy
we both got slightly sort of lost in
that as you do in those sort of scenes
i have a great memory of the two of us
lying at the end of the day in the
bottom in the hull of this boat looking
up at this amazing sky it was
baking hot beautiful day but obviously
after you've been out in it for
seven eight hours and both covered in
fake blood which in the sun
just gets stickier and stickier and um
both kind of lying there everything's
sticking together and
um but very pleased with ourselves that
we
pulled it off
ai artificial intelligence
i think it would have been late 1999
early 2000
you know i got that call that you all
will always want to get as an actor
which is
um that stephen spielberg wants to speak
to you and he
talked about how he had taken the mantle
of
a.i it came up very closely with the
time that stanley kubrick died so the
handover was either
early time early on in the production or
um had already been handed over but the
idea was always that stanley kubrick
would produce and stephen would direct
and there are a huge number of visuals
and and references to the worlds
that stephen created that were directly
from
kubrick's uh drawings and references
i went and met stephen in london we
talked a lot about this character
and then uh i rehearsed with him i was
making a film in
germany at the time called enemy the
gates and
i would fly to new york on the weekends
back when concord still ran
and i would rehearse over the weekend at
his at his place and then fly back and
carry on working in um
in germany that's where we dreamt up all
these ideas of the sort of
jukebox being inside gigolo joe's chest
and that he could click his
neck and change music and that he could
maybe dance and i said i'll learn to
dance i'll go and do dance classes i had
about four months and
again i went in with all these ideas of
being at a dance like gene kelly and
fred astaire and of course they said
you're probably 20 years too late this
time but nonetheless
threw myself into that we came up with
this very physical
uh language that seemed to apply to the
character stephen is one of those
brilliantly collaborative and um
inclusive creative spirits he
he he he led us that is me and the
choreographer come up with all sorts of
ideas that we would film
uh and that he would then reference and
we would sort of whittle
through when we were on set and the same
with the makeup i went over i remember
did an extensive makeup
test i moved over to la and we shot that
in 2000 and my uh my
eldest daughter was um was born during
the making of that
so it was a very happy time road to
petition
it was an unusual process this in a way
because in the in the in the
in the graphic novel the hitman maguire
kind of pops up at the end and
he i believe we kind of we we put quite
a few characters together he came alive
a lot more in the script but there was
still this sense of him being slightly
ambiguous
and very threatening like a kind of
angel of death in a way that sort of is
just one step behind but
but always on the shoulder of um tom's
character
sam and i had this extensive
conversation about how we make someone
threatening and memorable and
i was aware that you know they had tom
hanks they had kieran heinz they had
daniel craig all of whom were quite big
guys
and i thought that you know to make him
to make my character sort of threatening
would have been wrong to bulk him up and
make him
physically threatening so he decided and
said to sort of shrink him and make this
sort of wizard
rat-like character someone who's just uh
toxic in their soul
i'm something of a rarity
how's that i shoot the dead
dead bodies that is i don't kill them
we added all these sort of nails and bad
teeth and i
i shaved all my hair off back to here
and we kind of tried to really
turn him really into this bilious little
man
um obsessed by images so sort of lost in
his
art which is in itself a sort of
expression of
of his uh dark ways
working on that was was a
an extraordinary experience i was sort
of out on my own slightly because my
character was always um
stepping into the scenes just after
everyone else had left
i remember having an extraordinary
experience with
with paul newman he lived uh in the
apartment block i was in and he lived
above me or a couple of floors above he
was a
really generous guy very funny very
forthcoming with uh
stories and advice and uh he was lovely
i remember with my son
i had to keep telling him that we were
going for tea with butch cassidy but he
wasn't allowed to tell anyone because
butch was still on the run which he
loved at least he remembers to this day
cold mountain again with anthony
it was important from him to get me on
the location
as quickly as possible we shot a lot of
the a lot of it in romania
we went up very very early and helped
construct some of the village
together and there were no roads there
so we were riding a lot
digging a lot chopping trees it was just
coming out of the
chaichesky era and uh
rural romania was 50 years maybe 100
years behind
the rest of europe and their you know
milking
was unpasteurized so so you were
pasteurizing your own milk and
taking buggies to work on little um
muddy
hillsides and just being there was quite
a
a powerful way of stepping into the
world of cold mountain
anthony did a great job of i think also
creating the atmosphere by having
musicians on every set
he did the same actually on um ripley
where we had guy barker and
a lot of those jazz musicians stuck
around and played with me and played on
set just to create a sort of ambience
and he did on cold mountain actually
jack white
the great jack white was a part of that
and we would have music most days being
played
on set just to create an ambience in
in wp in
wp in repeating the thing doesn't
improve it
the great tim monach who i've worked
with several times worked with me on my
dialect coach but we always laugh about
the fact that
we work for months on my dialect and
then i barely talk in the whole film
because i've got this injury on my neck
that's not true i do talk a little bit
it was a
grueling shoot that we we started in the
baking heat
of the summer and went right the way
through to
sub-sub-zero temperatures up on the
mountains in the
in the snow i think it was about a six
month seven month
shoot and uh physically it was it was
pretty hard going every day was
a sort of uh you know ulysses
uh a test for inman and therefore for me
and um that that takes its toll after a
while
[Music]
what was extraordinary was uh nicole and
renee had their story and i had my story
and in a way we both went off and made
our own films and then we re-convened at
the end when the stories come together
and
having started together it was an
interesting experience to see each other
again
at the end and check in and find out
what their journey had been like
[Music]
closer we rehearsed it extensively but
mostly we rehearsed it sat around a
table
sharing experiences and really
unearthing the details of the
the characters and all that's in between
because of course it's
brilliantly structured in that you only
see people
meeting and then splitting up and all
the rest in between is
imagined so we were filling in lots of
gaps
it never felt stagey you know we always
felt
once we were on set the sets were very
real it was domestic it was
it was a lot of it was inside i mean
there were a few exteriors obviously but
most of it was inside
and that maybe lent it a sense
of of theatrical experience but but mike
nichols wasn't just the most brilliant
director and
creating truth and honesty and
uh and atmosphere
this will hurt i've been with anna
i'm in love with her we've been seeing
each other for a year
he began at her opening
really it was a case of just knowing the
thing inside out and
uh and obviously in a situation like
that when you have such great
players to work opposite on just a
four-hander
it's testing and it's challenging every
day to go to work but
of the best kind because you're going to
work and and
each actor sort of raises your game i
want anna back
she's made her choice i owe you an
apology i fell in love with her
my intention was not to make you suffer
so where's the apology
i apologize
don't cry on me i'm sorry
sherlock holmes i was sort of intrigued
by this project
uh and initially just sort of unsure of
the whole thing i didn't really know
what to expect um but then i met robert
and we got on very very well and
i thought suddenly meeting him and and
and then sitting with him and guy and
understanding what guy was bringing
it fit and it all suddenly sounded very
very exciting
it was clear from the get-go that they
really wanted to take it out of the
musty dusty drawing room physicalize it
you know that london the streets of
london and certainly the sort of
more uh or rather less salubrious and
more uh
dangerous quarters of london were places
where you had to
have your wits about you and you had to
be ready for a fight you had to know how
to fight in order to stay alive
and they wanted to take it into those
quarters i know that they didn't want
watson to be the sort of bumbling
idiot with his foot stuck in a waste
paper basket
following homes like a sort of lost
puppy and
they wanted to engage him more as a sort
of psychic and as someone who was very
much
observing learning but also contributing
and keeping
keeping his friend going in a way when
you um
analyze those books uh one of the
characters
is a functioning uh drug addict an
alcoholic and the other one is a gambler
and so they both sort of prop each other
up they both have their
issues and they both they both have
their sort of brilliance and
um and so we wanted to look into that
area
and it was a very exciting way to work
we would
get in early and run the scenes
as scripted and then sort of throw the
script out and improvise
i compiled this sort of bible of uh
quotes from the from the books
and we would go through and sort of mine
that for um good
quotes that we could replace our sort of
rather more modern
improvised lines with and
and then we'd go and shoot it very very
quickly so we do that most days so
uh as a team we work very
much together and uh we all felt like we
were very much in it and part of it
because we were contributing you know
in the writing and in the creative
vision
of it and then on top of that you had
all the wonderful action sequences which
are great fun to make
because you're dealing with huge camera
setups and
hundreds of people and explosions and
brilliant stunt men and
women and
yeah fun contagion
they've been outbreaks in the past
fishing industry suppresses it
industrial disease
yeah but it's just one man we don't even
know just one man on video
whatever has the foresight to die in
front of a camera the ones we don't see
worry me there was absolutely the sense
that this
was going to happen the great scientists
on set with us who had worked with
scott burns the writer and with stephen
were
very learned and experienced individuals
who knew
what to expect and they both or rather
they all said to us
that this was going to happen and um it
was a case of
when rather than if well first of all
the way they described it
which is exactly as it has happened
just made sense it's why you know they
they painted out all the
the obvious um areas and reasons why it
would spread so quickly
what's scary is is that you know you
learn
some you learn on a set on a film like
that because you're
you're being advised by experts but it
doesn't necessarily sit i mean that was
ten years ago let's say maybe nine so
i'd say that maybe
sat in my system scared the hell out of
me for all of what 18 months
and after that you know i don't know
that i was as aware of it as uh i
probably was when i came off the back of
it but when
2020 started and uh we heard about
what was initially happening in china
and what fast became apparent um around
the world
it it it rang alarm bells unfortunately
i wasn't hugely surprised
it's just that the studies show that
there is no proof that
works who conducted the studies what
defines works
the government rushed the trials the
lawyers
indemnified the drug companies maybe it
causes autism or
narcolepsy or cancer 10 years from now
who knows scott and steven had done a
huge amount of research and really sent
me all sorts of links
to different characters on the online
who were
gathering and building followings of
their sort of rants and predictions and
the characters they were sending me to
look at actually
you know they were far-fetched but they
were they were real and they were
happening and
so he's a cromweedy's a kind of um
collection of all of those
what's extraordinary maybe more than in
a way the uh
the virus spreading is how characters
like that have really started to pop
up as over the last nine years you know
our reliance
on uh tweets and blogs and uh the voices
out there
have become more and more heard
the young pope i'd seen most of paulo's
work and i just wanted to be in that
world i get this letter from him
and he he talks about this it's a very
simple two-page description of this
young ish um comparatively young
uh uh american man who
becomes pope but on becoming pope has a
crisis of faith
and uh smoked mulberreds and uh
drinks cherry coke zero and i was i was
immediately hooked i
just thought it was the most fantastic
premise
and in the hands and out of the mind of
a brilliant filmmaker
so i got him on board very very early on
and and he
proceeded to deliver this wonderful 10
hour tome
of work that we we filmed it from this
huge script that we shot like a movie
and
he then spliced into 10 episodes
originally
i do not have an image my good lady
because i am no one
you understand no one
only christ exists only
christ and i am not worth 45 or even 5
euros i am worth nothing
for me it was always the journey of a
man looking for his mum and dad trying
to understand why his mum and dad didn't
want him
and realizing that the only way he could
come to peace with that was from himself
and not from
anyone else including god on high
and no faith and no institution was ever
gonna
help him other than him finding peace
within
and then around him was this incredible
world
of the inner workings of the vatican
which he paolo brought to life
with all these wonderful actors so
colorfully and
eloquently and with great humor
and great humanity it's a real juggling
act
to pull that off to be able to make you
laugh make you
think make you feel with such grace
and paulo has it in you know just in in
pet spades
[Music]
what i love about power's work is that
sometimes you don't know whether you're
in a dream
whether you're in a flashback whether
you're in a fantasy whether you're in
reality in reality it's just as absurd
as
uh the dream you were just in and it's
for you to make sense of that
but sometimes his work is very
impressionistic sometimes it's very
specific
that's the realm we drift into when we
when we get told stories you know we
shouldn't always know
when a door is a door and a wall is a
wall sometimes things are meant to melt
and merge and you're not going to know
where you are your managers feel
we obviously had to uh film an awful lot
inside the vatican
inside the main cathedral and it wasn't
really ever gonna happen was it um
so it was reconstructed to scale at
china cheetah which is the wonderful
uh studios in rome where fellini
made all his films i believe martin
scorsese shot
gangs in new york there too the
attention to detail the passion thrown
into this production was extraordinary
we had
the tailors we had the vatican tailors
making
all of our papal robes and gowns
we had access to the vatican which meant
we could
recreate it really to to the minus
most minute details so the floor for
example
and the frescoes on all the walls were
photographed
in high definition uh for the first time
i think in history and were then
reprinted onto this incredible sort of
vinyl that they could then stick down
but actually when you go up to them i
mean
you could see the texture of the paint
and the texture of the marble on the
floor so
yeah the the the creative teams
behind uh the young pope and the new
pope were
just some of the best i've ever worked
with
fantastic beasts
what um joe rowling did was really fill
in
the past of albus dumbledore and and i
mean an awful lot of his past is
is hinted at and referenced in the books
of harry potter
she filled in a lot of gaps that weren't
mentioned in the book she also gave
insight and a sense of where he was
going and
what we hope to explore in in future
films i'm actually in the process of
making
the third fantastic beast at the moment
and that's exploring his
past in a little more detail
from now on i shall know every spell you
cast
i'm doubling the watch on you and you
will no longer teach defense against the
dark arts
i think what i like doing is is is you
know you go to source material and you
gain
insight reference and and then you you
i personally have to go away and sort of
flesh that out and create
a three-dimensional thinking breathing
operating human so that you can step
into
any given scene or any given scenario
and you know how you'd react and how
you'd respond and that's
to me the fun construction
deconstruction part of putting together
a character
the third day epona
look if there's something
hurting you here or scaring you
you can tell me my old friend felix
barra
came to me about seven years ago he's
the artistic director and the creative
mind behind punch drunk theater company
and they do these amazing they kind of
created immersive theater which is now
seen and celebrated worldwide and uh he
came to me about seven years ago with
the idea of
combining mediums that you could what
what if you created a
something that people could see at home
and i'm stealing his description here by
the way
uh and then as he says if then the
fourth wall just sort of
collapses and you can go into that world
for a live event
now initially the idea was that the
ritual that was going to carry out be
carried out
and hint and hinted at during the first
three parts of the drama
was actually going to be a real festival
that you could come and visit and we
were hoping to have 10 000 people come
to the island and be a part and interact
actually on the island with the
characters from the drama obviously
the pandemic hit and that wasn't going
to be real a real possibility so
so felix and uh sky and hbo and
mark munden one of the director of the
first three episodes came up with this
brilliant idea
with the writer dennis kelly of
constructing a single camera that would
follow the day's events in real time so
a combination
of sort of ethnographic slow cinema
and live performance and really make an
event piece
happen and so we went over as a company
just a
couple of hundred of us of the the
smallest element of the cast
and this single camera followed us for
12 hours on this
important day on the island of ose which
is hinted at through the first three
episodes i just want to talk
the nest the nest was this brilliant
script
that came to me from sean durkin who
uh had been on my mind since
for ten years since his his debut film
martha marcy maymeline and
it was a beautiful look at a family not
dealing with the loss of anyone not
dealing with a huge drama but just
dealing with
the each other and what it takes as a
family to survive day by day
and survive each other in a way that we
all have these
hidden layers and issues
that perhaps our families have given us
and
we have to work through them together
and uh he set it at a time
which was in if we look back now
in history a real turning point i think
when
the world became 24 7 and
uh the idea of more uh
as an answer to everyone's worries and
problems was was um
seen as a good thing things are dried up
here for me
what are you talking about i thought
things were great i'm running out of
options
but money's fine right yeah
right yeah in a way it was the sort of
birth of not greed i suppose in the
modern age and
rory o'hara the character i play was on
on first read
really i thought unlikeable but i love
the challenge of trying to
understand why he
would be followed why he would be
seductive and why
this brilliant wife of his would stick
with him
so it's a really beautiful love story
it's also a look at how perhaps it's a
modern
fable in in in in that
we perhaps got to where we are now
because we
sold democracy for consumerism
and uh it's a look at all those things
but it's dealt with
with incredible subtlety and grace it's
sean constructed a really
believable and beautiful family dynamic
carrie [ __ ] who plays my wife gives a
phenomenal performance as do
una roach and charlie who plays my son
it's a loving
and shocking and at times quite intense
phil